So the concept of a belief network, sometimes also known
as Bayes Net. Sometimes also known as Bayesian Network. Sometimes
also known as a graphical model. And there's other names,
but it's the same idea over and over again. And
the, and the idea is that what we're going to do
is we're going to represent the
conditional independence relationships between all
the variables in the joint distribution graphically. In terms of
of a little picture like this, where there's nodes corresponding
to all the variables. And, edges corresponding to dependencies that
need to be explicitly represented. So, the way that this
works is, what we can do is we can fill
in the prior probability of storm, which we can get by
just marginalizing out. So we've, we've already done an exercise
like this. So this is a number you should be able
to figure out. Then because of vary well, this is
also true that that you can figure out what the probability
of lightning is, given storm and also given not storm.
And these are numbers that you can just get by marginalizing
out. Finally, the probability of thunder, normally you'd have to
condition that on both storm and lightning. But as we already
talked about, it's actually conditionally independent of storm given lightning.
So, all we need to figure out is the probability of
thunder given lightning, and the probability of thunder given not
lightning. And once we have these, in this case five numbers,
that's enough to work out any probability we want
in the joint, just by multiplying corresponding components together.
So, what I'd like you to do is actually fill in these boxes as a quiz. And to
help you out we copied the numbers over from
the previous slides so that you actually have the
[LAUGH] values that you need to fill in this
table. because otherwise that would have been kind of mean.